all right we're working our way up to
number one and at number 23
there he is ryan's first day of year 17.
my teacher is mr rivera i am 38 years
old i am 74 inches tall
my friends are terry and curtis
and really great with the mean mug with
the mid-season beard makes it even
better
patrick he's been around for a long time
and
it was several years ago he was talking
about retiring and i think he ultimately
resigned himself to the fact i'm just
going to keep doing this
as long as i can and he gave us some
great moments last year with the
dolphins
and there's an expectation he's going to
give us some great moments this year
with the washington football team and
chris you've got him at number 23
so he's he's uh you know not top 20 and
i wouldn't expect him to be top 20 but
he's pretty damn close to it
pretty damn close like a dangerous
number 23 is what i would call ryan
fitzpatrick at the quarterback position
you know i think the the big thing i
would say right off the bat is like
you know screw-off fits tragic right
to me that's gone let's let's let's
let's bust some old narratives like
oh is it gone how do we know it's gone
because i've seen enough over the last
three
four years to go it's good enough play
to where i
fizz tragic is not there what what no no
no no in tampa look in tampa the year
that
jameis winston was suspended for the
first three games right and
brian fitzpatrick came out hot
and and there was talk well jameis lost
his job
it turned fitz tragic or james wouldn't
have been back on the field well yeah
he had he had he had a dip every time we
think he's great
he has a dip he had the game against
pittsburgh i know exactly what you're
talking about it was a monday night game
he threw four picks they had a chance to
even still win the game at the end
they were going back to jameis winston
no matter what he was the number one
pick of their football team
yeah maybe he could have played a little
cleaner but listen again that's where
it's like tampa like
tampa deserves some issues here too i
mean there's a reason he was reckless
jameis is wet reckless i mean there was
something going on there
but again that was still three years ago
so i
i don't really care guys change they get
better
they grow as players and to me that's
where he has grown as a football player
he's got a better gauge of like you know
balancing fits magic and fits tragic
you know like like we've talked about
where yeah
there's there's been those points for
his career where you just go what the
hell are you thinking you're supposed to
be from harvard and that's dumb mistakes
but they're few and far between now and
it's not like he's been on the greatest
offenses in football
here to talk about but either way
fitzpatrick
hey he's aggressive he makes plays with
his arm without having like
the strongest arm in football he moves
pretty damn well that's one thing when
you go back and watch ryan fitzpatrick
you watch games and you watch him run
you go damn i forgot he can run like
that
you know it's one of those things you
you forget about it and you know you see
the stats here mike it proves a little
bit that
fits tragic is slowly being wilted away
throughout his career
but the the last thing i'll say too and
why maybe i even gave ryan fitzpatrick a
little bit of a bump right
he's tough he's edgy there is
he does have a presence and an
edge that he brings to the football team
when he's the starting quarterback and i
do think that's real and guys can rally
around that and you kind of hear that
already in washington with guys talking
about him
and his attitude around the locker room
and things like that so
that's why i got fitzpatrick at 23. um
i'm i'm a fan and i think he could have
a big year in washington
well and and look i i don't disagree
with that and i'm rooting for him yeah i
just know that
that that that kind of anecdotal it is
that it's of being a football fan
when you write him off he plays great
when he starts playing great and you
think hey this guy is pretty good
it goes the other way and we'll see he
doesn't have the competition
this year you know he was in the same
spot as andy dalton
signed that one year roughly 10 million
dollar deal and then sit and wait to see
whether or not the team drafts a
quarterback
the bears did washington didn't and and
if
if your 49ers had gone mac jones at
number three
trey lance starts trickling down the
board in the top ten
entirely possible sure wft
jumps up and takes trey lance and it's a
different narrative for ryan fitzpatrick
yeah no doubt about it
in a long time where he enters as the
starter it was 2016 his second year with
the jets remember we had the one year
with the jets it was great
right and then 2016 he
signed right before the start of
training camp and that year was a
disappointment
it was but uh you know it's first time
since then that he's the guy and he gets
his chance and
how much of an upgrade do you envision
the quarterback room
led by ryan fitzpatrick for washington
this year under ron rivera then
last year when it was kyle allen
dwayne haskins alex smith and eventually
some taylor heinecke in the playoffs
well i just i feel like there's a
more of a playmaking element from within
the pocket with fitzpatrick in the room
now
that's the biggest thing i would say you
know alex smith yeah we
you know we talked about it it's obvious
yeah notice knows how to play the
position
manages the game does all those things
but not necessarily going to like
maximize all that's there to be had with
you know throwing the ball down the
field and making big plays and doing
that
so i do think it's a pretty good upgrade
as far as the quarterback position
is concerned i do let alone like we've
talked about
terry mclaurin is a rising star a star
already just
not everybody really knows about it yet
with curtis samuel added to the mix now
like he's got some real weapons and
you know again not that i'm trying to
say the guy is like
the most careful guy with with football
was saying hey no more fits tragic and
things like that
i understand there's still a reckless
part about him
but to me it's a more of a livable uh
recklessness to where
you know the interceptions i've seen the
last two years in miami i go uh
i get it i understand it you know as
compared to maybe years before you're
like
what the hell was that like how could he
even throw that
that's what i guess i meant by that
maybe i went a little too strong
but mike also to your point about that
you know i think we talked about this
two or three weeks ago ron rivera's i
feel like already like subliminally
talking to him in the media right he was
talking about
we got more support here in washington
the cam ever had in carolina and we got
weapons on this offense
i think that to me was a direct quote to
ryan fitzpatrick to like
hey we don't need fits magic every play
here we're good
and we got a good defense you know when
they're open throw it
if they're not let's be a little bit
more conservative than maybe you've been
in your past
it really is amazing when you look at it
st louis cincinnati
buffalo tennessee houston the jets
the buccaneers the dolphins and now the
washington football team a career that
began
back in 2005. same year as aaron rodgers
rogers has been with one team the whole
way
and uh and fitzpatrick has been with
pretty much every team but the green bay
packers
since 2005. and i'm rooting for him i
think it's a great story
and maybe as he gets closer and closer
to the end of his football
life he he is
relishing every moment taking advantage
of every spot and
making decisions and just not worrying
about it not worrying about tomorrow
not worrying about the next drive not
worrying about the next game
worrying about here and now and and
performing and enjoying it and getting
the most out of it and it was fun to see
what he did last year with the dolphins
yeah and uh we'll see a lot more of him
this year barring injury for
washington all right i was gonna say but
that's why i think it was such a gut
punch to him
you know to what you just said there at
the end to wrap it up that's why i was
such a guts punch last year when they
remember
the comments he made when they went to
tua because he was going damn i'm
playing good we got we're a good team we
can go we're a playoff team
you know so that hurt i'm sure yeah he
was probably enjoying himself to
to your point and all that so uh we'll
see maybe he gets another chance to lead
a team to a playoffs this year
i'm taking washington to win the nfc
east i'm just telling
you right now that is who i'm picking to
win the nfc's this year
we're going to draft the best known
quarterbacks in that division the nfc
east the weakest division in the nfl the
cowboys still the favorites but i agree
with you
i think washington's going to win that
division uh
we'll we'll see how that all goes in
pittsburgh we'll see how it goes as ben
roethlisberger who turned 49 or 39
not 49 not he he may play like he's 49
the birth certificate says only 39 he
turned 39 in march
uh you've got him at number 22. i know
man
that that is a stunner to me and i just
want
in the event that ben or anyone close to
ben is watching
these are sims numbers not mine
sims put him at number 22. he did it
defend yourself yeah well listen i like
big ben you know that i've been a
defender of big ben forever
i don't know it's tough to defend it
right now or know exactly where he
is at with his play he was definitely
one of the
tougher placements i had in this this
quarterback rankings
i mean yeah i could have justified maybe
moving them up a few spots
no doubt about it um you know but
like at the end of the day i mean what
rings true to me
more is what we saw the last six or
seven weeks of the year
you know is yeah a lot of short passes
you know some iffy decision making
certainly you know the offense itself
and you know what they looked like his
inability
to make any plays off schedule and do
anything like that
really became a statue and you know
maybe it's because of the knee issues
that we talked about him being bagged
banged up i certainly saw a difference
in play there
but you know everything about it you
know was not
great towards the end of the year and
again
when they were 9-0 you know if you
remember last year i didn't put them in
the top 10 quarterbacks in football
it was yeah they were 9-0 and things
were good i
understand that but when you really
broke down the play of what
he was doing it was good but it was
nothing special at that point
and they were kind of like you know just
squeaking by on some wins it wasn't like
we were just like wow this is the most
impressive 9-0 team we ever talked about
again remember what we were talking
about at the time it's one of the least
talked about
unimpressive 9-0 teams we had ever seen
so that's just you know again big ben
you could still wouldn't win with him
he's got a still a good arm but
lack of play-making you know i think
some of the decision-making towards the
end of the year all those things
concerned me and that's why you know he
fell to 22.
the knees i think are a real concern
yeah
there were chronic reports last year of
issues with the knees even though he
never showed up on the injury report
uh he's taken a lot of hits he's got a
lot of mileage
on the knees hips and ankles for a guy
who's carrying around a lot of weight
right
that eventually is going to catch up
with you we see him moving
less than he ever had before and now
this narrative popped up
kind of out of the blue over the course
of the last week that
well he didn't throw the ball down the
field as much last year because he was
still recovering from his major elbow
surgery and this year they expect more
of that
i thought it was the offense last year i
didn't think it was
the elbow i'm with you nobody said
anything about nobody as we were trying
to figure out what the hell was wrong
with the offense last year
no one was saying anything about the
elbow trying to heal
no that was never an issue how is it an
issue now yeah i and i don't buy that
i don't and i know he kind of said that
too like you know again whether he was
making an excuse or no excuses or
whatever
like listen if the guy has elbow
problems you don't throw the ball 608
times during the year if he was like
telling you every week
hey my elbow hurts my elbow hurts hey
you know what i think i'll fix that
let's throw it 48 times this weekend and
not run the ball
that's to me where i can't get behind
that you know that's to me where to me
it looks a little
excuse of like no i you know audible to
a lot of short plays and i just wasn't
aggressive enough in my
thinking and things like that and that's
why
you know we threw the ball short that's
what it looks like to me because when he
did throw the ball deep he threw it well
i wasn't sitting there going man that
looks weak
that looks soft no and i think that's
part of it too
how much of the blame do we talk about
the offensive put on big ben
you know there's certainly a number of
plays i can go back and watch and go hey
big ben check to this play i look he's
given the signals to the receivers
he's doing it yeah it's a three yard
completion and things like that
so i think all of that in totality what
we're talking about
is why i make him 22. and that's not to
say
you can't still win a super bowl or do
things but they got to help him and
protect him this year
and play a different style of football
and i fully expect them to do that
my big concern after that elbow injury
that knocked him out week two of the
2019 season was we were seeing the
beginning of the
end and the body was going to
systematically crumble
and yeah last year we didn't see him
miss
time for it but the knees were the next
step in it and i just
real i just 17 game season for a guy
who's 39
who definitely has not been a subscriber
to the tom brady exactly method right
and and it's gonna it's look tom brady
is still going strong at 43 going on 44
because of everything he's done and and
we know that ben doesn't do that when
you interviewed him at training camp two
years ago he
he doesn't spend a lot of time throwing
the football in the off-season no
and that's gonna that's gonna make it
harder for him to play deeper into his
life cycle than
a tom brady does yeah definitely in the
style he played yet you know throughout
his career like you've mentioned so many
times too it's as physical as you're
ever gonna find
you know as far as a quarterback in the
pocket just getting beat around but
you know again looking we're showing a
number of plays and big games here
down the stretch of the year where it's
miss throws it's bad location
it's it's bad decisions all together
you know it's a lack of yeah
pushing the ball down the field for some
times where i i do question whether it
was like
to protect numbers or not be the blame
of why you won or lost the game and
things like that
so you know again it was i don't want to
be disrespectful you know
i love big ben i think big ben is on the
borderline of being one of the 10
greatest quarterbacks of all time i get
a lot of flack when i say that
um so i don't feel good about making him
22 but
i think right now i think realistically
with the rest of the quarterbacks in
football
uh that's that's kind of how i how i see
it and i had no disrespect to
big ben big ben big ben big ben
if he can stay
[Music]
if he can stay healthy and if they can
get najee harris to do
in the running game what they so
desperately need the defense is still
very good
yes they're in a tough division they're
in a tough conference
it's going to be a tough road for the
steelers this year but they did get off
to an 11-0 start last year before the
wheels came off
and and and i believe and we've said
this a couple of different times
they got themselves thinking they can
just load up the cannon and do it again
address their weaknesses in free agency
in the draft hold the team together
and we're the steelers we know how to
compete and look mike tomlin's still the
coach he'll find a way
to make that team competitive whether
they're running the ball throwing the
ball
short down the field whatever they're
going to be competitive they're going to
be in games
and they're going to win games that's
right i i fully expected one thing we
know with pittsburgh
is they're going to be real they're
going to be honest with themselves
and mike tomlin is going to address it
and try to change it i think we can
we can guarantee that they got to you
know for all the reasons we've mentioned
again they lost five out of their last
six football games their starting
quarterback did not look very good and
their offense was lost during that
period
you know for a team that started at 10-0
that was a pretty you know
big crash towards the end of the year
with how they played
and of course that was all you know
really shown in the playoff game
where it all really reared its ugly head
bad decisions miss throws predictability
within the offense
you know lack of an ability to wait
nobody's open
okay nobody's open okay we got to get
out of the pocket make a play happen
just a little bit do some sort of
movement
to extend the play things like that
those are things that big ben's just not
going to bring to the table right now
it's not and that's why it's got to
change to the things you're talking
about
we have not yet if we have the graphic
that takes us up to 22. we have not yet
seen in the chris sims top 40
quarterback rankings
lamar jackson baker mayfield
joe burrow right which means that
roethlisberger is number four
i know in the afc north yeah what
game situation what scenario
would you take him above jackson borough
or mayfield
if any this it's i need one drive
to win the game in the super bowl maybe
that would be i think about it right now
because i think he'd be like well i've
been there and done that and i'm not
gonna feel the pressure of this and i'm
i'm big ben big ben
i'll bring us back like that's one where
okay i'll throw that out there right now
huge playoff game huge super bowl moment
i might take big ben to just go wait i
think he can make the right decision the
proper throw and he won't be overwhelmed
by the magnitude of that situation
the problem is those are situations that
come at the tail end of the wear and
tear
right right so physically what's he got
left at that point i know
you're right and also as i sit there and
say it i just think well man i'd like a
guy that could extend some plays too and
do some things like
that to find some open people in those
situations uh but i i guess if there's
one scenario
i would think about that but certainly
like yeah he's not as talented as that
crew
i mean not right now i mean damn that's
those are three good ones for me
we know lamar's a stud baker is entering
stud territory for sure
and joe burrow is was looking very
studly before he hurt his knee so i mean
they're they're they're the guys and in
my opinion i got a lot of respect for
those three it's not about disrespect
for big ben
so if we're on the playground and we're
drafting a team for right now
the last of the four quarterbacks you're
taking that's of those guys is ben
for anybody again for clarification yeah
this is what
this is we're all on the same team this
is my
top 40 quarterback depth chart it's
really it is oh this guy got hurt here's
the next guy oh this guy got hurt here's
the next guy
that's what it is so yes he is 22nd in
the nfl and fourth in the afc north
well uh again it's chris sims
quarterback rank
direct all mail i i i'm wasting my time
right
they're still going to say directed to
mike florio screw him i don't have any i
get it
yeah on your behalf email
twitter i'm gonna i'm gonna dox you one
of these days i'm gonna put your email
address out there so they can
they can just communicate directly with
you because i'm telling you anything you
say anything you do i have to hear about
it
i get it i like it that way yeah that's
good it's a good work
it's gonna it's gonna take more than a
lawrence taylor jersey
for me to ever feel good about that hi
i'm mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports